- [Jeremy] Hey everyone,
this is Jeremy Schefen
at Khan Academy.
Wanna wish you a happy Friday
after week number five,
can you believe it?
Since this all started.
I know, like, the way of
doing things in the past
feels like the distant
past all of a sudden.
But we really appreciated everything
that educators are
doing across the country
to further students in this time of need.
And we especially appreciate
your fellow-educator, Jessica,
who's calling in from Brownsville, Texas,
where she's an English and ESL teacher
and is using Khan Academy
for the last two years
to serve her students in
a really effective way.
So, Jessica, thank you so
much for being here today.
- [Jessica] Thank you for
inviting me, I appreciate it.
- [Jeremy] And just to
give folks a sense of how
they can interact with you,
we're gonna go after some
of the basic things about
Jessica's background as an educator,
how she recommends that you
start using Khan Academy,
if you're just getting started this week.
But then if you have specific questions,
you can ask those via the
GoToWebinar questions feature.
Just type them in and we'll take those
as we go into the session.
And Jessica can really walk you through
whatever's on your mind.
So, that being said, Jessica why don't you
tell folks a little bit about your own
educational adventure and how you got
to where you are as a teacher today?
- [Jessica] Well I'm an English, ESLL,
English One teacher in Brownsville, Texas.
Our demographics are pretty unique.
We have very high, low
socioeconomic students
and I also have a large
percentage of ESL students.
We have 2,500 students in my school.
We have six high schools.
And out of our 2,500 students,
about 350 of them are EL's.
And we have about 100
students who are newcomers,
which means that they're
at the beginning level,
as far as we can tell from English.
As far as English language learning.
So they are beginners.
I am certified as an
ESLL English One teacher
four through eight and
eight through 12 in Texas.
I also hold technology
applications certifications
for eight to 12, grades eight through 12.
We are SIOP-trained.
We also embed a lot of
technology into our classroom,
we're very lucky to have
access, as ESLL teachers,
to iPads and Google Chromebooks,
and all the different
technology that we can use.
So, we started using Khan Academy about
two years ago in the classroom.
And it was pretty interesting because
we found that a lot of our ESL students
lacked the basic grammar and functional
English language skills that we
didn't really have time to sit and teach
for long periods of times.
So we needed to find
a way to kind of embed
those skill sets and those TEKs,
along with our ELPS, that we are required
to use in Texas, by using Khan Academy.
And it was really amazing because,
for our newcomers, we started off,
you know, two days a week for them.
And they really started picking
up on the grammar basics.
You know, we went over nouns...
You know, verbs.
We went over punctuation
and we used Khan Academy
as a way to bridge the gap.
And because it was visual...
And it allowed them multiple
opportunities to kind of
do the questions without fear of failure.
So it was really, really great for them
because they were able to see it in
a non-threatening environment.
And we also used Khan Academy because I do
computer science after
school with our ESLs.
So Khan Academy also
has really great program
if you're looking for some
interesting things in there,
like they have Pixar
in a Box and they also
have computer science, so
we use it across the board
in our school district.
- [Jeremy] Very cool and so...
Obviously, Khan Academy
has all these tools
and there's all these other
technology platforms out there
but if you were in the shoes of a teacher
who's just starting with technology
or just starting with Khan Academy today,
and trying to serve their
English language learners,
but now over a remote distance,
are there any tips you would give them
for just getting started
serving that audience?
- [Jessica] I would.
One is if you do have
access to Google Classroom
and your ISD has logins for your students,
you can automatically log them in
to Khan Academy using Google.
And when you log them in, all they do
is they input their login
credentials from the school,
which makes it so much easier to connect
to the actual classroom
and then you're able
to give them the class code.
So that way they can sync with it.
That really helped us.
And we did it in small
chunks when we first started.
When we started, 45 minutes a week.
And then we expanded to
longer periods of time.
But we really focused on the skills
that they were missing.
Because we have our yearly
STAAR end of course test
in Texas, our data is
always pretty current.
So we look at what our
students were struggling in
and then finding ways to kind of remedy
those areas, in order to
strengthen them for the test.
So what we found was our
kids really struggled
with editing and revising.
Because they didn't have the
basic foundational skills,
so we started small, we started with nouns
and simple sentences.
And when we did the simple sentences,
we would embed the Khan
Academy for the structure
and then we would bridge
it to a piece of writing
and have them identify noun, verbs.
So they still get the
reading and the writing,
and then we were able to those skills
and move the ones who were
a little more advanced
could move on.
And the ones who struggled, we were able
to identify them more.
And be able to work on them one-on-one.
So it's about small chunks at first.
Until you get really
comfortable with the program.
And I really liked that I could see,
and I would go and check, "Hey, did you do
"so-and-so assignment?"
and I could see whether or
not they viewed the video,
I could see what they
got on the assignment,
and I would tell them,
"If you're struggling with
"the assignment and you
didn't watch the video,
"you should probably go back
and see where the video,
"what the video has to say before
"you even start the assignment."
- [Jeremy] Very cool,
I think that's such an
important piece of advice right now,
when everything feels so overwhelming,
just start small.
One lesson,
- [Jessica] Start small.
- [Jeremy] One assignment,
if your student can
sort of get that experience
under their belt,
before you move onto the
bigger and bolder things.
- [Jessica] And what's really
great is you can start,
if you do nouns, for ESL especially,
you have to work on the cognates,
depending on what their language is,
where they struggle.
Luckily, we're in an area
where most of our students
are Spanish-speaking and most of the
people here are bilingual.
But that might not be so in other areas.
We also have a population of...
A population that speaks Tagalog.
So with that, it's really helpful to use,
like we use our Duolingo,
we use our Khan Academy,
we use our Flipgrid in order
to kind of bridge the language.
So what we do is we start with nouns
and then we give an assignment on nouns.
So everything connects...
together.
And then we'll give a STAAR question
that has, like, identify or edit
whatever topic we're working on.
So everything's just kind
of streamlined, I suppose.
- [Jeremy] Very cool.
So now that we've sort of covered
some of the basics about like how you
would get students registered,
what would you give them
as a first assignment,
how would you look at
some of those results,
let's take them to some of the
next step questions from the audience.
So Lisa asks a really important question,
which is so much of this is in text
and obviously many ELLs,
especially the newcomers,
really struggle just getting started,
what do you do to sort of serve them,
given this sort of
text-based focus of many of
these Khan Academy questions?
- [Jessica] So the way we did that also
was we used a variety of models,
so that's why it's
important to start small.
You don't want to give
them too much too fast
because it gets very difficult.
We do a lot with dictionaries
and we start this,
I know it's hard right now,
but we make use of all
the online dictionaries.
So if you have a Spanish-speaking student,
the best online dictionary
that we have found
has been spanishdict.com,
I believe that's the...
Website address.
It's one of the better, yes that one.
It's one of the better
Spanish-English translators
and it's one that our
students use all the time
to translate some of those
text-based questions.
We start...
If you're not in too much of a rush,
you can start small like
a noun is a sustantivo.
So we do a lot of bridging with the...
The primary language.
Because academic language
does take five to seven
years to kind of learn, so we bridge a lot
with our...
Home language, which is
part of our ELPS in Texas.
Where we're allowed to use the
home language of the student
in order to bridge those gaps.
So we try to at least...
Kind of...
Translate the main ideas
like noun or not a noun.
One problem my kids struggled with
in identifying nouns was when the names
were from other countries.
Like I think there's a
couple names from Japan,
a couple names from
other countries in there,
so they really struggle with that because
they weren't used to other names.
So we had to go over that.
So what I would do is I did mini lessons,
as I was discussing earlier.
I did mini lessons and I
upload them to my YouTube.
So if the students are
asking me questions,
that I know they're gonna
struggle with, or concept,
instead of doing a live Zoom,
I do a mini lesson and then
I upload it and share it.
That has been by far the easiest for me.
It's really...
You can look up cognates,
things like that,
just to help kind of bridge
that gap in the language.
I'm not sure what language
that your students speak,
just from experience from my
Spanish-speaking students.
- [Jeremy] Very cool
- [Jessica] I hope that helps.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, that actually speaks
to a great question from Paula.
Which is what's the most user-friendly
sort of video engagement tool
when you're working with an ESL classroom?
And it sounds like
instead of trying anything
really fancy or maybe complicated,
YouTube is something that
students are really familiar with
and it's easy for you, as a teacher,
to quickly record a video on your phone
and then share with them, is that right?
- [Jessica] Yes.
For me, I get a little, kind of...
Overwhelmed with everything
that everyone shares
like Edgy Puzzle and all of these things
and I'm like, I don't have time to learn
another platform right now.
So I've been sticking
to what I know is like
using my phone, I had recently
a lot of my EL students,
we were doing poetry
and they kept asking me the same question,
so really quickly I
pulled out my cell phone
I recorded a three minute video.
Really easy, just explaining to them
and showing them what I needed them to do.
And then I uploaded it
into a private YouTube
and then I shared it with
them via my communication app,
which is what I use is
Remind and Google Classroom
since they're already all in there.
Because we've been doing a
blended classroom for a while.
So I share it to them and then that way,
they're able to access the
video on their own time.
And that way they can
do it at their own pace.
It's really important for ESL students.
We have to...
Let them do it at their own pace,
even more so now because...
The fact that we're
not right next to them,
that's one of the most
difficult things with this
online learning is not being
able to be there with them
to kind of guide them into
what they need to know.
So that was the easiest way for me
was doing it through
video on my cell phone
and then just uploading it.
- [Jeremy] And the other--
- [Jessica] It's not fancy,
there's no razzle dazzle,
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- [Jessica] But it works.
- [Jeremy] And the other thing that you
had pointed out before, Jessica,
was just that...
Especially for low-income students
where they may only be a single device
or no device at the home,
synchronized communication
may actually be really difficult,
especially if there are siblings there.
And so that actually
leads to a direct question
from Amy, who also has a
number of low-income students
who only have phones at home,
not Chromebooks, not laptops.
How would you recommend
that they use Khan Academy,
if at all, given that all they
have are their smartphones?
- [Jessica] That's a really good question.
So before they gave me
my newer Chromebooks,
we had like an older cow and
so half the laptops would work
and the other half would just,
they just didn't work at all.
And so what we did was my student,
one of my student was like,
"let's try to download it
"on your phone and see what happens."
So we did and it is
actually mobile friendly.
You can download Khan
Academy onto your phone.
And you can still assign
them lessons from it.
And they're able to
access it on their phone,
which has been a real life-saver
for us too because of the
inaccessibility to reliable internet or
Chromebooks because we're
not a one-to-one district.
We tried to give out as many
Chromebooks as we could,
but we ran out rather quickly.
And the same with the
hotspots that we delivered.
We ran out of them before we could
give them to every single student.
So because we're not one-to-one,
we do do a lot of it on mobile.
And my students used to
turn it in all the time
after school, before school, some of them
would even use it in class,
when their laptops would die.
So it is very user
friendly on mobile as well.
- [Jeremy] Great.
Let's see here.
Alicia's asking a really good question.
Do you recommend always
assigning the videos
or only the activities
and the quizzes themselves
and then let the kids watch
the videos on their own
if they choose to?
- [Jessica] I always for my ESL,
you have to gauge what
level your ESL kids are.
So I have varying levels of ESL students.
So the ones that are in
my English One SL classes,
are brand new to the country,
they speak very little English.
So for them it's required
for them to watch the video.
And I only give them one assignment.
And then I look at the data.
So once they've done the assignment,
I look at their scores
and see if they're ready
for like the mastery sections,
and then I'll assign those sections
individually or at the same time
when I feel as though they've
mastered those skillsets.
Because if they're still
scoring in 60s and 40s
and then I see that I need to go back
and maybe do a mini lesson really quickly,
upload it or assign a coordinating text or
something where they can
identify nouns or verbs
or comma splices and then that way,
I can see where I can remedy those areas
that they're weak on.
I would say for ESLs that are beginners,
it should always be required
that they do the video.
It's just more beneficial for them.
If you have someone who is
more intermediate and advanced,
you could probably do the lessons first
and then if they're struggling with it,
assign the video.
- [Jeremy] Very cool.
Now a number of teachers,
including Stephanie,
are asking is Khan available
in different languages?
And so Khan is actually
available in 44 languages
as of this moment.
So, question for you Jessica,
do you ever have students,
especially those newcomers,
switch to the Spanish-language
version of Khan Academy
or do you always have them
use the English version,
sort of build that
expertise over time.
- [Jessica] So what we
do for those students
is they actually put the subtitles.
They put the Spanish subtitles
so they can read it and then
listen to it at the same time.
Again, you would have to
gauge where your students are.
Academically, some may
come with lower levels of
fluency in their home language.
With that, you may want to have them
watch the video in both languages.
But most of the time,
they use the subtitles
on the videos in order for them to
read it in Spanish and hear it in English.
- [Jeremy] Great.
Okay, let's see here.
Oo, okay Vernetta wants
you to really go deep here.
She's really curious about all these
platforms you mentioned.
Like spanishdict.com and Duolingo.
Are there other programs
that you enjoy using
and that you would really recommend
to fellow educators in this moment?
- [Jessica] We also use Flipgrid a lot
in the ESL classroom and we use Nearpod.
For Flipgrid, I really like Flipgrid
because we have a standardized test
at the end of the year
that tests our English
secondary learners.
Every year when they're
enrolled in Texas school,
it's called the TELPAS.
And in the TELPAS, they
have a speaking portion.
So we use Flipgrid and
we'll ask them a question
based on the questions they'll
ask them in the TELPAS.
Sometimes it's, "Tell me a story,
"tell me what they're
doing in this procedural."
And so it really helps them get used
to speaking in English.
And being able to take that
test at the end of the year.
So we use that, Duolingo.
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- [Jessica] Yeah, I'm thinking
there's so many.
- [Jeremy] Do you think Nearpod
would be a good thing at this point or...
- [Jessica] Um....
(sigh)
If you haven't done it, probably not.
But it's something you can look
into for the following year.
But Flipgrid, definitely.
Definitely is a great tool, so if the kids
can't share their writing,
they're more than likely
they're gonna try to speak.
And you can, what I
like about Flipgrid too,
is you can...
Moderate the video so nobody
else can see them but you.
- [Jeremy] Absolutely.
- [Jessica] ESL kids are
nervous about speaking.
- [Jeremy] Yeah and I'll just say having
a couple kids at home myself,
I know that Flipgrid is such a great way
to keep the lines of communication open
- [Jessica] Yes.
- [Jeremy] Because it really
creates this back and forth pattern
of engaging with the educator
and the family at home.
So just a nice way to sort of
let them know you're still
there and thinking of them.
- [Jessica] Yes.
- [Jeremy] Speaking of next year,
I know that we're very much focused
on the here now.
How do we get through the next hour?
How do we get through the day?
How do we get to next week?
But for educators who are
already thinking about,
"Whoa, we're gonna have a lot of students
"with a lot of gaps
heading into September."
Is there any way for data to carry over
from Khan Academy this
year to the students'
Khan Academy account for next year
so that data can be used
in subsequent years?
This is a question from Clarissa.
- [Jessica] I think it should be because
they're logged into your classroom.
So sometimes what we do
is before they even leave
is we'll take all that data out
and because they're ESL kids we actually
have our ELPAC committee.
And so we use a lot of that data
and so we give it to the next teacher.
- [Jeremy] Cool.
- [Jessica] So, before they
leave us we're able to give the
next teacher all their data.
Their test scores, their Khan Academy,
everything that they have.
Until you delete that, they
stay in there, but I'm not,
I've never had it transfer over.
That's probably something I should ask
but our school's really big.
- [Jeremy] Yep.
- [Jessica] It's like
2,500 students and a lot of teachers.
And I've never really asked
the English Two teacher.
I feel kind bad now because I'm like,
"Maybe I should go ask her."
- [Jeremy] Oh yeah, absolutely.
Definitely check with her.
I will mention,
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- [Jeremy] Technologically,
it's totally feasible.
- [Jessica] Yeah, totally feasible, yeah.
- [Jeremy] As Jessica
mentioned at the very beginning
is that your student
is creating an account
with their school email or
the Google Classroom login
or whatever.
And that single account can be
logged into multiple classes
on Khan Academy at once.
- [Jessica] Yeah.
And as long as you don't--
- [Jeremy] So if you
- [Jessica] Archive it or delete it,
it'd still be there.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, so if you
come into the learner view,
which you can always see from your
name in the upper right hand corner.
You can actually
- [Jessica] It'll have that
join multiple classes, so.
Your ELL class...
Your science class, your math class,
all those teachers can be working
with a single student account.
That data can be shared,
as Jessica mentioned.
- [Jessica] And I will also
say, it's not just for English.
A lot of our Biology teachers,
who teach our ESLs, we also
use Khan Academy for Biology.
We use it for Algebra.
We use it for...
SAT prep.
So it's not just for the grammar sections.
We also use it in other core content areas
within our school.
- [Jeremy] Very cool.
- [Jessica] For our ESLs.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, I will mention that Khan
not only has a broad
sort of range of content,
- [Jessica] Oh yeah.
- [Jeremy] We're actually
official partner with
the college board on SAT.
So for the students who
are all freaking out
about the canceled exams
and how do I stay sharp,
that's always available and that's
been blessed by the folks
who make the SAT themselves.
- [Jessica] And we do
have some EL students
in our AP sections and
we have them practice
the SAT and ACT through Khan Academy.
- [Jeremy] Very cool.
Now, speaking of all this content,
Amy really wants to get into the specifics
do you recommend any particular units
or lessons or exercises that would be
really effective for ELLs.
And to add a little more context,
Amy actually works with adult ELLs.
So she's trying to figure out what,
of all this content, might be most useful.
- [Jessica] That's really interesting
because we did host a
few adult ESL classes
at our school for about maybe six weeks.
And so we used it...
Again, what we did, is we did a pre-test.
So always start with some sort of pre-test
in order for you to gauge where they're at
because you don't want to
start too low or too high.
Because either they'll get
bored or they get frustrated.
So we give a pre-test out
and from that pre-test
we can see where they can start at.
What skills that they can use.
I mainly start from
concrete and abstract nouns
because those are some
of the most difficult
kind of...
Things that the EL students
are having trouble with,
is the concrete and abstract nouns.
Also, they have a lot of
trouble with foreign endings.
Which is on, I believe,
on the grammar sections.
And so we start with those first.
So they can have an idea of what to use.
Also, conjunctions, they really
struggle with conjunctions as well.
- [Jeremy] Cool.
- [Jessica] I hope that helps
- [Jeremy] You just mentioned
that every single course on Khan Academy
has this course challenge at the very end.
- [Jessica] Mhm.
- [Jeremy] So again,
in this case I click
into the grammar course,
I scrolled all the way down to the bottom,
and you can assign this course challenge
as an easy way to sort
of get pre-testing for
here's where folks are,
and then when you go back
to actually assign
specific pieces of content,
you can really use that to inform
very differentiated approach.
So just like
- [Jessica] Exactly.
- [Jeremy] Jessica mentioned,
if you know some folks
are very much advanced, some
folks are just beginning,
you can assign not to your entire class,
but to specific students,
these are the ones
who need this material,
here are the others,
who need something different.
Very important question from Chris.
Is Khan Academy free or does our school
need to buy licenses to
access all this material?
- [Jessica] No, Khan Academy is free.
And so you can get your
kids started right away.
You don't need licenses, they
can access it from anywhere.
That's what I really loved about it
was that it was such
an open access concept.
And it was really
beneficial for our students
and for our district.
We have 50,000 students
in our district, so
it can get pricey for us as well.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, absolutely.
And just to be clear,
this is not one of those
free until the end of the school year,
until the end of the crisis,
- [Jessica] No.
- [Jeremy] Khan Academy's
actually non-profit, so
as long as we keep
- [Jessica] Non-profit, yes.
- [Jeremy] Fundraising
money, there will be
Khan Academy for every
teacher and every student.
- [Jessica] Yes.
- [Jeremy] Okay, here we go.
This is an interesting question.
So Justin says, "I teach U.S. History
"to high school students
and their native language
"is Chinese.
"There are in ELD one and two.
"What sites would you suggest,
"especially now, given
everything that's happening
"and how do you recommend they use Khan?"
So thinking about maybe
that kind of audience
specifically focused on social studies,
any tips you might give Justin?
- [Jessica] I'm trying to think of LD,
is that like beginner?
- [Jeremy] Yeah, I think
that's what he's getting at.
I'm not
- [Jessica] Oh, okay, okay.
- [Jeremy] And obviously
there's a U.S. History
course on Khan Academy.
- [Jessica] Yeah, there is.
- [Jeremy] But it is fairly
like English heavy, so maybe
that's what he's speaking to.
- [Jessica] So, when you have
really English-heavy things,
the best thing to do is
just chunk everything.
You don't want to give
them too much too fast.
So if you're going to go over something,
even if you give them a passage to do,
you wanna chunk that.
And the same would go for
using things like this.
So you want to give them key
vocabulary ahead of time,
even while using the online platform.
So if you were to take a look at what
Jeremy has pulled up,
where is says things like
continent, history, North American,
what you want to do is you want to give
them those words ahead of time
and have them try and translate it.
Because you'd surprised
how many EL students
already have their own translators.
My students are constantly,
"Miss, can I use a translator?"
And I'm like, "No, you
have to use a dictionary."
because the test requires a dictionary.
But, so what we do is we have them
kind of showcase those
main vocabulary points,
so when they go in, they kind of already
have an idea of what the
content is gonna be about.
That's part of the SIOP method,
where you're able to give
them the key vocabulary
and keep focusing on
those key vocabularies
and that key concept in small chunks
and still be able to use like
maybe one or two questions.
You know, from it.
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- [Jessica] And then that way,
they know exactly at
least those key ideas.
It's not perfect, but it allows them
an opportunity to gain
more academic language.
And it's just, you know, using
pre-vocabulary strategies
to help them kind of bridge their gap
when speaking another language.
- [Jeremy] Very cool
- [Jessica] I hope that
was helpful.
- [Jeremy] I think that
actually segues perfectly
into this really important,
- [Jessica] Okay.
- [Jeremy] High level question
from Permal, which is,
"This is a difficult thing
even in regular times,
"but in these abnormal times
that we find ourselves in,
"how do you create a productive
struggle for students?
"How do you balance the desire to
"translate everything for them,
"with the need for them
to grapple with English?
"Are there any tools or
strategies you recommend
"to find that balance?"
- [Jessica] So because in
Texas we do have our ELPS
and so from the beginning of the year
to the end of the year,
we have this timeline
that allows us to use
primary home language
and then kind of wean them
off of those translations.
So at the beginning of
the year, it's 80-20.
And then we go into...
And when we say 80-20, it's not bilingual
because in the secondary sections,
the secondary high school
levels and middle schools,
we don't do bilingual,
does that make sense?
It's kind of like, "Okay, this
is road, but you say calle.
"All right what is calle?
"It's road."
So we allow them to bridge L one to L two.
So we start them off with that bridging,
but we work a lot on cognates.
And this is just Spanish,
but you could probably
do it in other languages too.
You find the commonly used words
that you're going to be
using within your classroom.
So if you teach math, what
is a common vocabulary
you're going to be using all the time?
That common vocabulary
needs to be used constantly.
You need to be saying it so they can hear
how you're say it, so that
they know what it means.
A lot of visuals, a lot of...
You know when you're using a concept,
you put it up on white, I know
you can't do that right now,
because it's online.
But you can also do it in a video.
Where you just kind of keep
going over those same concepts,
so they can get the lesson.
And you chunk the answer,
you chunk the questions,
you chunk the readings, and
then as they get further along,
you start expanding to
more rigorous instruction.
And that's why we do so much at
the beginning of the
year with Khan Academy.
So they can kind of bridge that language
and we're there to help them,
we have their dictionaries there,
we take vocabulary lists, so that way
by the time we get to
this point in the year,
we've already gone to English-only.
- [Jeremy] Got it, great advice.
I know we're almost at time here.
And there's still many
more questions out there.
So one last question for you, Jessica.
- [Jessica] Okay.
- [Jeremy] Is if you want
to get support on Khan Academy,
either how to use a
specific piece of the site,
or talk to other educators, are there
any resources that you would recommend
to get those questions answered?
- [Jessica] Yes, there is a Facebook group
for Khan Academy educators and you can
ask questions in there.
There are a lot of
ambassadors also online,
on Twitter, who will give you advice
and be able to help troubleshoot.
The Khan Academy for Teachers page though,
is extremely beneficial.
There's tons of teachers
who are answering questions,
and asking questions.
And it's a great way
to connect with people
who have already been using Khan Academy
for a long period of time and
those who have just started.
- [Jeremy] Great.
I'll also just mention very quickly here,
Those are all volunteer educators,
just like Jessica,
- [Jeremy] Who are going
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- [Jeremy] Above and beyond
right now to help out.
If you ever have a very technical question
that you want that answer
by Khan Academy staff,
just go up to your name in
the upper right hand corner,
come down here to the help section,
and then all you have to
do is say report a problem.
It doesn't have to be a
formal, technical bug.
But just a question about
how to get something done,
pen that in and let us know and we will
respond back there.
So, Jessica, I know we're at time.
I want to thank you so
much for making time
to share your expertise today.
And pay it forward to the next
generation of Khan teachers.
And I want to thank
everyone else out there
for making time out of
their busy schedules
to invest in this session.
- [Jessica] And I want to thank everybody
for trying their hardest
during this difficult time
in working with the EL students.
You're doing such great work and
you're in the right place to help them.
And Khan Academy can help you do that.
- [Jeremy] Wonderful.
Well, with those words, let's head into
a well-deserved weekend.
Thank you all for everything
you're doing right now
to make your students
lives a little brighter.
And thank you again,
Jessica, for making us
all a little smarter this afternoon.
Have a great weekend.
- [Jessica] Thanks for
inviting me.